relapse I started drinking white wine
doing and then riding my bike in 98
degree weather from Bushwick to Harlem
it was not good wild the fact that I did
not die is crazy that's insane when I
tell you my ass was High I mean I was
high my ass was high everything was high
what were you going to Harlem for oh on
Caine for [__] no just just the ride
the music was good my speaker was fully
charged and I said
you know what that's even that's
progress though I mean I'm glad you're
not relapsed whatever but to go to get
cardio in on Co yeah much better than
what you used to be doing oh no
absolutely much better than like you
know in my mind I said if I ride I'm
riding off all of the Demons right which
I'm this is how dumb I am makes sense to
me yeah you know like I'm like have you
done
it have you done
it you